[音楽]
padi
6年前から挑戦していることがあります
それは平戸をグローバル化することです
平戸は人口3万2000人ほどの小さな島です
この写真の右下はプラドで一番栄えている街の写真です
歴史とロマンの島1響き合う宝島
をキャッチコピー実際に美しい自然と豊かな歴史文化がたくさんあり私はそこで育ち
ました
主な経済は第1次産業と環境業で成り立っていますが実際高齢化が進み
仕事は減少しています
とくに女性は
イキイキと楽しく働く場所は少なくなります
そして若者は地元を離れていってしまうため
20代の男性女性
極端に少ないんです
ここで私は
女性が新たに活躍する場としてファッション産業を生み出す
持続する仕組みづくりに挑戦しています
具体的にはオリジナルブランドを作り
それを枚取れ生産し
国内と海外で展開しているんです
ではなぜファッションなのか
それは私がとにかくファッションが好きで一生仕事にしたいと思うほど
ファッションニトリファッションに救われてきました
ファッションが好きな理由はコンプレックスからです
コンプレックスは誰しも抱えていると思います
私の場合
ファッションがそれを武器に変えてくれます
私のコンプレックスは
幼少期から太っていて
妬み僻みばかりを口にしては人に嫌われていると
思い込み
人を恐れるような性格だったんです
つよがりから明るく振る舞うことしか出来なくて
人の顔色を伺っては人と話すことが嫌になっていました
心体的なコンプレックスは大きくて
テレビや雑誌を見る女の人たちを見るといつかあんなふうになりたい
でもその反面鏡を見るとこんな自分の姿を皆にさらけ出してるんだと思うと
なおさら苦しくてここから抜け出していつかあんなふうになりたいなと思っていました
自分に自信がなくて
それが改善されると思っていなかったんですが
ある時体はすぐに変えられなくても
ファッションは自由に変えれるんだと気づき
そこから私は8勝で自己表現をし始めます
本来ファッションは自由で
自分の好きなものを好きな時に来ていいんですよね
私はよくすごい格好してるよね
いや真似できない格好してるよねと言われます
それは
私はそう言われると
素直にありがとう
と喜びます
それは私が自分の体のプラスポイントを知っていますし
人にどう見られたいかもわかっています
それ自体が私のコンプレックスに当たるからです
長続きしない私が唯一時間も惜しまず没頭できたものがファッションでした
さて
私がファッションを仕事にしたいと思いながらも
最初に就いた職業は教員でした
配属先は故郷の全校生徒39名の小さな小学校でした
これはその小学校から見える海の写真です
ここで働きながらそれまでと社会人になってから見えた
平戸の姿は違っていて
窮屈だった場所は
四季折々が表情豊かに変えて
生きるということを体感させてくれたんです
ここで育つ子どもたちは目がキラキラしていて
自然と人との関係がとても近く
家族同様に周りの人たちとクロール協力し合いながら田植えしたよ
海で遊んだよと楽しそうに生活しています
この中で
将来漁師になって
釣った魚を私に食べさせてくれるという子もいました
しかし
その一方で
そこに夢を見せられない大人たちがいます
現状大人たちは
自分たちが高齢化で
低所得で悪戦苦闘しているため子どもたちにここから出て行ったほうがいいと言うん
です
子どもたちは大好きな平戸にいたいと願いながらも
進学や就職で仕方なく枚堂でていくしかないんですね
結局は私も
辛い現状から教職を止め
ヒラ胴ハナレ
ファッションの仕事をすることを決意しました
そこで
ファッションスタイリストを目指しながら
どこで
何のために働くのか
納得いくまで探した結果わかったことは
やりがいの充実と
喜んでいただくことでした
しかしそれは一人ではかないません
人を惹きつける人間力が必要だと思いそれをどうしようと思うと
少し視点を変えて周りを見てみるとその存在がいました
それは私の母でした
そして
人と比べることを止め
元気で明るく愛情あふれる母のようになろうと私は自分を変えていったんです
おかげで私は自分のことが面白い人間だなぁと思うようになりました
もっと可能性があると思うと楽になってやりたいことが明確になりました
平戸のために何とかしたいという思いから
学びなおすとこ今日は
身近でかっこよく見えて
歴史的に世界の窓口であった文化の可能性が今もまだあると気づきました
それを原動力に
グローバルなファッションブランドを作ったことによって
地元の女性が活躍する場ができてきています
6年前
人脈も経験もない中一人で始めると決めました
ファッションがとにかく好きなんだとアピールし周りの厳しい県には耳を貸さず
やったらできるという熱意だけで取り組んできたんです
失敗は当たり前で
そこを見向きもしませんでした
反骨精神で
一人で決断しましたが
仲間や先輩方に当初から支えられています
そして今では素敵な仲間達がいます
20代から60代の幅広い組織になりました
現在の私たちの挑戦は将来子どもたちが楽しんで働ける職場をつくっていくことです
実は
それは地元の小学生が実際に私たちと一緒にここで働きたいと言ってくれたことが
きっかけなんです
だからまずは30年
これが続くように頑張っていきたいとおもいます
こうやって地元の女の子が活躍するチャンスをつくり続けていることにとても興奮して
います
そして多方面からいただく叱咤激励や豪運に対してお返しになれば
喜ばしい限りです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]